[Music]
the year is 1953 the U.S purchases this
from Bell Labs the first commercial
silicon solar cell
but these first solar cells are not
exactly efficient
if you were to put them on your roof and
try to generate electricity it would
cost you about three hundred thousand
dollars a month fast forward 70 years
and that cost has come down way down
solar energy is the cheapest it's ever
been nearly 90 percent cheaper than it
was just in 2009 in a lot of places it
is now cheaper to generate electricity
with solar than with coal natural gas or
nuclear power
this is an unqualified success story and
if we can take the right lessons from it
this story can help us create and deploy
all the other technology we will need to
keep our planet livable
[Music]
thank you
they just became cheap so quickly it's
really an amazing breakthrough that is
going to come to define the 21st century
so how did solar energy go from
prohibitively expensive to cheaper than
fossil fuels
we're in an energy crisis now in the
1970s with the oil crisis there's a
really big push on research and
development for alternative energy today
and directly harnessing the power of the
sun we're taking the energy that God
gave us and using it to replace our
dwindling supplies of fossil fuels
with project Independence as it was
called the U.S federal government
allotted more than a billion dollars to
solar research and development that
really made a huge difference and
probably doubled the efficiency of the
set
there was a guy named Paul maycock who
came from Texas Instruments oh like the
calculators yeah working on calculators
and he found for calculators the more
they built the cheaper the calculators
got and he said same thing for solar if
we build more the cost will come down
but before the us could really test
maycock's idea President Reagan canceled
project Independence
fortunately two countries were ready to
step in and put maycox hypothesis to the
test
like the U.S Japan had been hit hard by
the oil crisis in the 70s they started
funding solar research and development
around the same time and soon they
developed solar cells small and powerful
enough to run watches calculators and
toys trivial in terms of the global
Energy System but crucial in that large
companies were now becoming interested
in solar and crucially figuring out how
to construct solar at really low low
cost that know-how came in handy when
the Japanese government announced a
major subsidy for rooftop solar in the
mid 90s but the global market for solar
technology was still relatively small
until Germany stepped in and truly
changed the game the most important
policy on this whole chain if I had to
pick one it would be the German feed-in
tariff feed in tariffs which was
basically a program that deployed solar
at scale here's how it worked starting
in 2000 the German government basically
said to power companies hey if you can
start producing renewable energy we will
buy it from you we promise for double
the market price and we will keep paying
you at that rate for the next 20 years
and so for uh developers of solar
projects in Germany all of a sudden it
became like a no-brainer to do this even
though Germany is not the sunniest place
in the world companies responded to the
incentives by building solar Farms like
this one in one year the installations
for solar went up by a factor of four
and then it just grew the more panels
they produced the cheaper it got to
generate electricity with solar then
another country picked up the Baton and
made solar cheaper than even maycock
could have imagined
so it really starts with Deng Xiaoping
in the 1980s and had this plan for a
thousand Chinese students to go abroad
and come back and see what they came
back with one group of students went to
the University of New South Wales in
Australia where they worked with a team
that was producing some of the most
efficient solar cells in the world after
a few years one of those students went
back to China and opened up the
country's first commercial solar
manufacturer Suntec in 2002 with that
new German law in place the company had
so much success selling solar panels to
Germany suntec's success attracted
competitors which helped drive down
prices in part because all of this
demand inspired Chinese manufacturers to
produce at an unprecedented scale policy
makers around the world noticed the
falling prices and wrote laws to create
new markets in their countries including
the United States the United States
passed an important law it's called the
energy Policy Act 2005. and buried deep
within that law was an investment tax
credit sounds kind kind of boring but it
turns out it was absolutely critical to
deploying solar because what it said was
that if you put out a new solar project
you can get 30 percent of those costs
back for a tax credit this sparked a
phenomenon called solar leasing where
companies would look for places to put
solar so that they could reduce the
amount they owed the federal government
and taxes
other policies helped create markets for
solar modules in Spain Italy and
crucially in China the Chinese devised
their own subsidy program that was
modeled on the German one where you get
a guaranteed price by 2011 the China was
not only the biggest producer of solar
but the biggest producer of solar
electricity
in the course of a single lifetime solar
energy has transformed from a niche
technology to the cheapest way to bring
clean reliable power to billions of
people around the world but the markets
that brought us these lower prices
didn't just magically appear by some
invisible hand political leaders in
countries all over the world created
these markets then subsidized them for
decades to the tune of billions of
dollars by investing that money you got
the solar to come down in cost so to the
point where you don't need to subsidize
it anymore we're doing that on purpose
with things like batteries and electric
vehicles we're doing that with things
like heat pumps solar provided us with a
playback for how to do that for other
Technologies
[Music]
foreign